[Music]
hey everyone welcome to other
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
Harry Potter potions and Severus Snape
when Harry was in his sixth year at
Hogwarts
he developed a glowing reputation with
his then potions professor Horace
Slughorn Slughorn and returned to the
school this same year and sought to
connect Harry as another prize for his
wall of successful pupils fortunately
for cyclone Harry wanted to be collected
so that he could question him about
another former pupil Tom Riddle things
couldn't have worked out better for
Harry and when he first attends suck
Holmes class he's without a textbook
when he arrives in class is instructed
by Slughorn to go and find a spare
textbook in the classroom little did he
know at the time but Harry hit the
jackpot as he found the former textbook
of the half-blood Prince
aka Severus Snape at first this was just
a regular textbook to Harry but as he
began to flip through it he noticed a
few peculiarities the first thing that
he notices in his copy of the advanced
potion making textbook was an
inscription by its former owner his book
is the property of the half-blood Prince
the next thing that he notices is that
on each page portions of the
instructions are scribbled out and
instead this half-blood Prince character
had written in his own instructions
instructions that differed from what the
original recipe called for what Harry
quickly realized was that these
alternative instructions were far better
than the original instructions as he was
able to effortlessly produce the potions
the Slughorn called for in each of his
lessons the book was like having cheat
codes to all of the potions lessons and
by following the instructions in the
book Harry was able to thoroughly
impress
Slughorn for the rest of the week's
potion lessons
Harry continued to follow the half-blood
Prince's instructions wherever they
deviated from light beiges forages with
the result that by their fourth lesson
slow Colin was raving about Harry's
abilities saying that he had rarely
taught anyone so talented so Slughorn
was impressed to say the least
and after a while Slughorn started to
post about Harry
as if he
the best student that he had ever taught
stop sulking and come and join us
Severus hiccuped Slughorn happily I was
just talking about Harry's exceptional
potion making some credit must go to you
of course
you taught him for five years traps with
suck horns arm around his shoulders
Snape looked down his hooked nose at
Harry his black eyes narrowed funny and
never had the impression I managed to
teach Potter anything at all well then
it's natural ability a shattered
Slughorn he should have seen what he
gave me first lesson the draught of
living death never had a student produce
finer on a first attempt I don't think
even knew Severus we know that Slughorn
taught Severus Snape the half-blood
Prince himself so if Harry was simply
following Snape's instructions how could
he be a better potion maker than him
Harry by himself was never all that
talented at potions so it seems unlikely
he could have surpassed its names
abilities nonetheless sluggin has this
to say of Harry's ability I don't think
I've ever known such a natural of
potions says Slughorn regarding Harry
with a fond if bloodshot eye instinctive
you know like his mother
I've always wondered why he would say
this if Harry is simply copying Snape's
recipe surely Snape who came up with the
alternative recipes in the first place
would receive credit for being most
talented was Harry somehow better than
Snape in a way that we just haven't
realized if we break apart this
situation a little bit I think we can
find some answers the most important
thing to remember is that Snape was the
one who originally corrected the text
book full of faulty recipes and
scribbled in his own this method Snape
would have had to have been the one to
first try the inferior recipe and then
through trial and error come up with his
own superior recipe Snape had an innate
talent for potion making but no potion
master particularly one who's still a
student would have all the answers
without first making a few blunders
while a student of Cyclones is like it
the Snape shown through at the star
pupil due to his ability to always
eventually produce a perfect batch of
whatever concoction it is they were
producing however given the Snape was
the one who actually had to try and
perfect these
peas in the first place it would have
taken him much longer than Harry who
only had to open the book and follow the
instructions to tea from the outside
perspective
Harry produced the same potions that
Snape did except he did it faster and
with no errors though Harry received
high praise from psych horn for his
potion making ability at the end a day
it was really all Snape and Snape should
be the one to get the credit I would
imagine that Slughorn praising Harry and
his potion making ability would have
been particularly annoying to Snape and
that's it for this video if you enjoyed
the content please be sure to LIKE the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]